alors que les relations se corsent entre
Washington et Pékin c'est au tour d'un
nouveau Comité sur la compétition avec
la Chine
de présenter sa stratégie des efforts
robustes nous dit-on maître de côté la
partie zannerie politique et s'entendre
sur la stratégie à adopter contre la
Chine
dit-il c'est lorsque démocrate et
républicain travaille ensemble contre le
Parti communiste chinois parmi les
témoins et charm of master qui était le
conseiller à la sécurité nationale
soudain qui a toujours averti le congrès
de ne pas affaire à faire avec la Chine
les États-Unis sont maintenant derrière
la Chine dit-il
Tanguy fait partie des témoins qui vont
s'adresser au comité cette interprète
pour un dissident politique chinois
avait été accusé d'avoir dérangé l'ordre
social elle avait été envoyé aux travaux
forcés ou elle avait été battue dans les
années 90
nous les États-Unis avons aidé à nourrir
le bébé dragon dit-elle qui est devenu
le Parti communiste d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les témoignages ont été brièvement
interrompus par trois manifestants qui
scandaient que la Chine n'était pas
l'ennemi des États-Unis
on sait que les Chinois nous espionnent
ouvertement avec leur ballon et
secrètement avec leur technologie dit-il
ils achètent aussi des terrains
agricoles il faut qu'on soit vigilant
dit-il pour les dissuader avant qu'il ne
nuisent à notre souveraineté Tik Tok
n'est juste la pointe de l'iceberg déjà
10 projets de loi sont sur la table pour
bannir l'achat de terrain agricoles aux
États-Unis par des entités affiliées au
gouvernement chinois
dépression en politique et économiques
alors que les échanges commerciaux entre
les États-Unis et la Chine étaient de
près de 700 milliards de dollars en 2022
tout ceci alors qu'on soupçonne la Chine
de vouloir armer la Russie dans le
conflit contre l'Ukraine
on sait qu'ils n'ont pas écarté la
possibilité dit-il ce serait une grave
erreur de la part de la Chine d'envoyer
des équipements militaires à la Russie
destiné à bombarder des villes en
Ukraine la Chine doit rester à l'écart
chinois
du ministère des Affaires étrangères
parle d'une campagne de salissage contre
la Chine alors que des médias américains
rapportent également que le covid
proviendrait d'une fuite d'un
laboratoire à Ouran en Chine
après plusieurs audiences la commission
parlementaire va remettre ses travaux
d'ici à moi ici Radio-Canada Washington